boa tarde pessoal
eu queria agradecer a oportunidade está
aqui mas eu queria fazer alguma pergunta
quem é que tá com saulo a quem consegue
viver sem celular num quase ninguém é eu
pergunto quando eles quiserem comprar um
novo ou o que vocês estão agora quebrar
ou simplesmente surgiu uma supernova
tecnologia
você sabe o que faz e vai fazer com esse
salário do nosso bolso aí
guardada fazer quase como se fosse um
museu de antiguidades é pilha é
carregador de celular 95 aqueles tijolão
gigante né pois há muita gente tem essa
dúvida e que quem não tem essa dúvida
joga no lixo mesmo
isso é o que a gente chama de resíduo
eletroeletrônico ou simplesmente lixo
eletrônico
e aí quando eu falo sobre o celular e
quando falo sobre resíduos eletrônico na
verdade estou falando sobre quase tudo
que tem na vida da gente é micro ondas é
videogame a televisão aqueles freezer de
lojas de conveniência é aparelho dvd t6
lembra desse aparelho cvt de que ninguém
mais nos negócios
outro problema que é resíduo eletrônico
e ninguém se dá conta que os materiais
biomédicos
esse equipamento de raio-x radioterapia
tudo está equipamento de resíduo
eletrônico ou eletroeletrônico se
entenderam o problema gigante que a
gente tem quando simplesmente descartar
esses equipamentos que vai acontecer com
isso daí a gente gera hoje no brasil em
torno de 7 quilos de resíduos
eletroeletrônicos por habitante fazendo
américa população brasileira dá mais ou
menos 1.5 milhão de tonelada ao ano
só para vocês terem uma comparação de
quanto isso é na cabeça de vocês
isso dá mais ou menos 20 milhões de
pessoas com 75 quilos
é isso o que a gente gera de resíduo
eletrônico no ano todo o que fazer com
isso a onde vai isso quem vai trabalhar
com isso
como é que a gente resolve esse problema
e tem outro detalhe o governo não sabe
quanto desse problema daí quanto esse
número é reciclada e quando está falando
de eletroeletrônico a gente tem um novo
termo novo conceito chamado logística
reversa gente vive no mundo hoje de
extremamente do extremo consumo do
sistema de capitalismo a gente consome
consome consome então as indústrias vão
lá produzem a gente utiliza a gente
descarta e agora ele precisa
reaproveitar esse é um conceito da
logística reversa
mas de quem por exemplo esse retorno que
a gente tem que fazer nessa cadeia de
quem é a responsabilidade
na europa e nos estados unidos eles
indicam que essa responsabilidade é do
cara que produz aqui no brasil pela
política nacional de resíduos sólidos
essa rede é essa responsabilidade é
compartilhada quem comercializa quem
importa quem compra quem vende quem
recicla quem vai descartar também esse
negócio
então todos somos responsáveis por esse
resíduo e por esse equipamento que está
sendo destinado de alguma forma
e aí esse conceito de logística reversa
e pela polícia nacional é um conceito
sócioeconômico porque eu falo isso
porque quando você descarta o
equipamento e ele vai ser reaproveitado
uma nova rede é criada para utilizar ele
e aí eu tô falando de recondicionamento
ou seja quando pega um computador velho
e bota ele pra funcionar novamente ou
mudando uma peça ou outra remanufatura
quando o bota na indústria novamente com
equipamento de segunda categoria digamos
assim ou a
o o recondicionamento a utilização
remanufatura como eu falei e
simplesmente o descarte em depósito
adequado que é extremamente difícil de
fazer isso ainda hoje
e aí nesse ciclo de logística reversa
esses três
o recondicionamento a remanufatura ea
reutilização eles voltam pra a etapa de
utilização outras pessoas que não vocês
que descartaram eu descartei vão
utilizar esse equipamento porque em
geral ele continua funcionando
regularmente e perfeitamente quando a
gente fala deste carro adequado e
reciclagem
a gente está voltando esse equipamento
de novo para a indústria sem precisar
utilizar ou extrair alguma coisa do meio
ambiente ver como isso a bacana e
interessante na política nacional de
resíduos sólidos tem um forte apoio para
que as cooperativas de catadores e
associações elas possam trabalhar nesse
processo de recife receber esse material
destinar esse material para a indústria
e fazer é essa venda e receber por isso
há obviamente é como é que eles fazem já
sabem está com até chegar no nível o
volume ideal para a indústria e ele
simplesmente vender isso daí o projeto
que eu participei junto com a fundação
joaquim nabuco o limite ea usp
ele tinha como um grande foco ajudar as
cooperativas com esse debate com um
governo que eles já fazem e com a
indústria que eles já fazem
mas mais do que isso é com centralizar
eles pelo processo de d
a separação desse equipamento e dar
melhor
a manipulação desse equipamento que pode
acontecer se a gente a não utilizar por
exemplo os materiais adequados ou as
proteções adequadas pra separar o
material de resíduos eletrônicos
esse debate também foi há muito colocado
pra as empresas do governo porque elas
também não sabe o que fazer com esse
equipamento que acabam sendo
cartazes então tem aí uma série de
bancos universidades institutos que tem
um monte de computador parado um monte
de impressora parada e não sabe o que
vai fazer com que lhe dá lhe a ea gente
também aumenta o contato com a sociedade
para mostrar informações sobre isso daí
em um outro detalhe o que a gente vai
fazer uma série d o que a gente fez e
está fazendo é uma série de projetos e
protótipos que vão ajudar essas
cooperativas a entender a gestão desse
resíduo e aí a gente teve encontrou na
verdade um projeto três grandes desafios
para implementar esse sistema de
logística reversa
o primeiro deles já sabem os pontos de
coleta porque estou falando de ponto de
coleta
o primeiro porque a gente não sabe
quando vai acabar a vida útil desse
aparelho está na mão de vocês ou de
muitos que você está em casa e nem
quando você vai descartar esse material
então tem um ponto de coleta fixo na
cidade o município é super interessante
pra você mensurar a quantidade de
equipamento que vai ser reciclado
remanufaturado ou recondicionado tá
indústria ou para outras pessoas mais
nem eu nem possivelmente vocês sabe como
ajudar e sistema de logística reversa e
o sistema também de reciclagem
possivelmente só para vocês terem uma
noção de qual o problema com a confusão
que existe nesse aspecto e ponto de
coleta na região metropolitana do recife
foi feito a consultoria que a gente
deveria ter
eu vou repeti a gente te ver ia ter 160
pontos de coleta de latas eletrônico na
cidade
eu não conheço nenhum
e aí o apesar disso o estado de
pernambuco fez duas leis uma em 2009 e 1
em 2013 que disse o seguinte as empresas
que comercializam alerta eletrônico
precisam virar pontos de coleta
ou seja eles vão receber esses materiais
descartados e aí eles estipulam prazos e
multa para essas empresas que
simplesmente não cumprirem esses essa
lei
isso é bem legal que o governo fez um
avanço pequeno mais interessante
outro problema grave e outro grande
desafio é a rastreabilidade por exemplo
a gente tem um acidente ambiental na
amazônia saber da onde veio esse
material é super é importante pra gente
saber como punir os responsáveis por
aqui dali e como prevê ou pelo menos
tentar que isso não aconteça novamente
então saber de onde vem esse equipamento
gera uma confiança no sistema de
logística reversa para punir as pessoas
que estão sendo responsáveis de
simplesmente jogar o resíduo em qualquer
lugar
outro desafio é o que a gente chama
balanço de massa por exemplo hoje se
você quiser reciclar ou descartar um
monitor crt
lembra aqueles monitores grandões pronto
a
é muito complexo você reciclar esse
negócio primeiro porque em geral quando
você coloca no mercado na rua as pessoas
tiram a parte posterior desse monitor
para vender o que ele chama de cromo
deste material
isso é muito grave porque em geral
quando eles fazem isso obviamente tem
chumbo tem mercúrio a tem cara e manter
um bocado de é de substância é que vai
aqui você pode se contaminar com aqueles
ali e as pessoas em geral estão fazendo
isso mas pensei direitinho
eu estou falando uma cooperativa eles
recebem
sei lá 10 20 e 30 monitores ao mesmo
tempo então que eles fazem o que eles
não conseguiram fazer a partir do
projeto da gente
se o monitor dance por exemplo é que
vale mais ou menos a três quilos e um
monitor
eles passam passando três e 15 13 15 e
um monitor desses acaba vindo com 15
quilos primeiro você sabe que já tem
alguma coisa errada nisso daí alguma
coisa foi retirado esse monitor vocês e
para ele e vai tentar rastrear aquele
aquele material para tentar punir as
pessoas que fizeram isso para que isso
não aconteça novamente
os estudos que a gente fez identifica
que a cada mil toneladas de resíduos
eletrônicos e equivale a 59 novos
empregos na indústria recicladora então
imagina se a gente pega aquele dado que
eu falei de 1.5 milhão de toneladas ao
ano e multiplica aqui dá mais ou menos
750 mil empregos novos no brasil
o problema é que isso não está sendo
respeitado
esses equipamentos ainda estão sendo
colocados em lugares inadequados estão
grave pra ver problema para o país
eu sei que existe um esforço enorme do
brasil do governo brasileiro de fazer
com que essas leis sejam de fato
cumpridas e e sejam executadas por todas
as pessoas
mas enquanto nós sociedade civil a gente
ainda não sabe os riscos que possam
acontecer
acontecer com a gente num um contato
direto com esse resíduo nada muito grave
nada muito diferente vai acontecer não
só pra dar um exemplo pra vocês
em 1987 aconteceu um acidente com césio
137 que aconteceu em goiana a um
sucateiro ou 11 tratador pegou no
hospital uma máquina de raio-x levou pra
casa para retirar esse equipamento para
poder comercializar dentro dessa desse
equipamento de uma cápsula com césio 137
que parecia ser uma substância
extremamente ofensiva e quando desligava
luz ela iluminava então eles ficaram
muito impressionados levaram pra casa e
vários familiares e pessoas da
vizinhança da comunidade acabaram
falecendo
com esse equipamento e com esse com essa
substância
obviamente o desconhecimento desse risco
dos cuidados de manuseio desses é que
desse tipo de equipamento por um
obviamente as principais causas que 20
mou tanta gente nesse acidente
só que mais grave a olha é isso que eu
queria passar para vocês
esse equipamento era fonte de renda
desse catador era a forma como ele
tirava dinheiro para o sustento da
família
então como é que a gente pode melhorar
isso e como é que a gente pode ajudar
outras pessoas a ter informação para que
isso não aconteça novamente
e essas substâncias elas estão no dia a
dia da gente a gente perceber por
exemplo dentro do smartphone tem
substância chamado perry lio esse
barulho causa cansa mais do que isso têm
outros minérios raros níquel índio que
quase ninguém fala sobre eles mas eles
são extremamente tóxicos à ilha
por outro lado ela já está extraindo
desses resíduos
vários desses materiais é inclusive o
índio eo níquel pra quê
para não ter que voltar de novo para o
meio ambiente pra colocar nesse
equipamento no brasil pouco tem feito na
cidade de maneira adequada
e à contaminação por esses equipamentos
podem acontecer de duas formas a
primeira é obviamente eu estou quebrando
um monitor crt em tem uma série de
substâncias ali eu vou me contaminar por
bioacumulação ao contato direto na pele
isso é muito grave isso pode dar
problemas de saúde rapidamente ou por
vários e vários anos e você nem perceber
o perceber futuramente isso é
extremamente grave e uma outra forma
várias pessoas quando vão tirar esse
resíduo é para tirar materiais como ouro
ou alguma outra eles queimam e se for
somente esse equipamento e aí a partir
do momento que se usa o vento ou queima
você vai na la esses essas substâncias
tóxicas
isso é pra em grave tem muita gente
fazendo isso em casa sem nenhum cuidado
sem nenhuma proteção e isso é
extremamente delicado
voltando para a região metropolitana de
recife
esses são dois cenários que a gente
encontrou de estocagem desses
equipamentos quando vão para a
reciclagem
esse é um caso vocês podem ver aí
extremamente sem cuidado no piso ou
identificação do equipamento
um outro caso um pouco melhor mas ainda
também sem identificação do equipamento
e uma separação a categoria
e aí na estocagem de resíduo a gente
encontrou esses três cenários o primeiro
nas assistências técnicas
então as pessoas levam os equipamentos
ou eles vão ser remando faturado para a
indústria ou seja um computador normal
ele vai lá modificam com as peças de
volta ou para ser revendido ou para
outra pessoa três ali ou simplesmente as
pessoas deixam lá na assistência técnica
e ela que se vê de novo aquele material
um outro cenário são os sucateiros que
eles entendem estes resíduos como sucata
de metal não quer que eles vão fazer
eles vamos tocar em algum desses
cenários que vocês viram daí quando
tiver um volume ideal para a indústria
eles vão vender para indústrias
um outro cenário é da destinação e
inadequada
isso é o que mais acontece e eu queria
mostrar uma história pra vocês
essa é uma foto que foi retirada no
jornal do comércio de pernambuco em 2013
terão repercussão internacional e contou
a história de paulinho que os meninos aí
na foto e de várias outras crianças que
estavam no canal do arruda
catando latinha de alumínio eu não sei
se vocês conseguem ver nessa foto um
detalhe crucial e eu vou dar um destaque
para vocês verem se consegue entender o
que é isso aí
isso é um monitor crt com a parte
posterior de quebrada
como eu falei pra vocês
o monitor crt ele é vendido e culpa o
cromo que é retirado desse monitor
ele é vendido por 12 reais o quilo mais
ou menos que cinco vezes mais do que ela
tinha de alumínio que paulinho tá aí
catando no canal do arruda
a latinha que paulinho está catando os 2
50 o quilo
o cromo que o cara tira desse monitor os
14 reagir já é um absurdo o cenário que
podem estar colocado e ainda assim a
quantidade de outras substâncias
extremamente mais perigosos inclusive do
que essa de que ele já está exposto um
negócio extremamente hostil e
complicadíssimo para se viver muito
ainda é preciso ser feito sobre esse
aspecto da dos resíduos sólidos e dos
resíduos eletroeletrônicos as
informações ea informação sobre isso
precisa chegar a todas as pessoas
a forma como a gente encontrou de ajudar
esse problema tão gigante aí que a gente
tem
foi ajudando o governo a a protótipos a
uma ideia que eles chamam de ceni e
depois vou explicar um pouco melhor
sobre o cene a ea partir do momento que
a gente protótipo essa idéia junto com a
light ea fundação joaquim nabuco
a agente também ajudou a cooperativa a
entender o trabalho dela mesma as
cooperativas começar a entender que a
saiu muito da cooperativa por exemplo um
carrinho ou com a carrocinha ou a
própria mente com o caminhão e fazia o
percurso sem normas sem nenhum
planejamento isso é obviamente
extremamente a um produtivo para a
empresa para a cooperativa
a associação então a gente começou esse
cuidado de obviamente mostra a
informação sobre esses resíduos e também
desenvolveu uma ferramenta para que eles
pudessem utilizando o cene é esse
cenário aí de gestão a um sistema
nacional de informação sobre gestão de
resíduos sólidos que ele vai mapear onde
estão esses resíduos e documentar quando
você a entregar algum documento há algum
resíduo dentro da associação ou da
indústria recicladora
então não sei se vocês sabem muito bem
como é a realidade de uma cooperativa de
catadores
mas é essa realidade eles têm até alguns
equipamentos que foram doados
é mas eles não conseguem utilizar
direitos e principalmente porque
simplesmente não tem espaço suficiente
para que isso funcione adequadamente
esse é um outro processo aí pra fazer as
a compactação do material mas também uma
outra ferramenta que está parada dentro
da associação e de outras várias
associações
isso é o que eles chamam balanço de
massa eles pegam um caderninho a nota o
valor do material que foi colocado na na
associação e tentam fazer com que isso
essa informação chegue ao governo a
associação ao município que ele queira
vender aquele material mas vocês
conseguem compreender que isso não
funciona direito
então o material chega na cooperativa o
descarte já tem já está sendo feito lá
em pernambuco o governo em geral as
prefeituras dos municípios pois
municípios do governo geral todo todo o
estado
ele já consegue fazer com que essas
associações de recolha de material num
volume razoável que interessa inclusive
para a indústria recicladora mas o que
falta é a gerência desse processo e é
isso que a gente trouxe de novo e de
inovação para esse projeto
então a partir do momento que ele pega
esse material
ele vai registrar esse material numa
foto vai pesar esse material de forma
adequada e vai localizar um ponto gps
onde foi coletado esse equipamento isso
aí vai um sistema que ele vai mensurar a
todos os aspectos de localização ao tipo
de material pra eles planejarem as novas
ações que eles vão fazer a nos próximos
anos nos próximos meses
então como é que isso acontece esse é o
primeiro protótipo é o primeiro celular
que eles utilizaram na associação se
eles têm celular na associação eles
coletam inclusive 45 celulares por dia
então eles têm como utilizar celulares
para fazer essa coleta a e aí a gente
utilizou uma série de a possibilidade de
identificarem os equipamentos refere de
qr cozzi pelo próprio código de barras
de alguns equipamentos já dá pra
presidente ficarem e essa é a recolha tá
dentro da carrocinha dentro do caminhão
a dentro da própria cooperativa eles têm
esse a esse sistema que eles podem
utilizar então eles vão ter a oab khan
ou celular vai ter a imagem eles começam
a identificar
é o equipamento a conseguem cadastrá
cadastramento tudo feito e aí eles
entregam um documento oficial
isso é extremamente necessário para
transformar esse sistema nos cabeça uma
coisa confiável então se as empresas
entregam os catadores e não tem essa
documentação fica tudo perdido aqui não
a partir de agora não a gente tem essa
documentação para levar para as pessoas
que estão descartando aquele material e
aí um outro aspecto a essa é a rota que
fazem mas que ao menos diariamente em 22
dias
vocês estão vendo aqui é metade da
cidade do recife
para fazer isso ou de caminhão ou de
calcinha
é um sacrifício vocês devem imaginar mas
aí tem uma coisa interessante que hoje
conseguem ter e se instalou lá no ponto
site daquele mapa
se vocês vão perceber eu vou tentar dar
um destaque tem ao ponto site
e aí que acontece aqui no ponto 7 são
várias coletas na mesma comunidade
então ele identificar que aquela
comunidade inteira tem várias outras
pessoas que querem entregar alguma coisa
e sim as pessoas no próprio sistema
dizem 8 o material para ser entregue
nessa comunidade nessa posição então
eles vão lá recorda esse material podem
começar a mapear o material que foi
recolhido e aí esse sistema acaba dando
uma uma segurança para eles para mandar
essas informações inclusive pelo governo
posteriormente
então o que eu queria passar aqui é que
esse sistema de logística reversa a
extremamente necessário para o mundo que
a gente vive hoje porque a gente vive
num mundo com tecnologia completamente
fmi era de um dia para o outro ou outra
lá muito mais moderno eu quero vocês
querem uma nova televisão vocês querem
eu também quero então é um mundo
completamente capitalista
só que a gente pode fazer a partir desse
processo de carregar essa com que o
impacto para o meio ambiente seja
reduzido então se a gente consegue fazer
isso daí
e ainda mais aumentar esse processo e
criar essa rede de economia circular
para que outras pessoas possam entrar
nesse processo perdendo dinheiro
estruturando suas famílias
entendendo que pode ganhar inclusive
dinheiro com esse equipamento é
extremamente necessário interessante
para o nosso futuro a gente consegue ter
uma qualidade de vida melhor tem um
menor impacto possível no meio ambiente
e continuar com a boa economia para o
mundo todo então era essa
meu convite pra vocês espero que vocês
queiram dar esse salto comigo é muito
obrigado